borderline medical malpractice if a
doctor's gonna try everything in his
power regardless of what the aspect of
the new york times sake do you think
that the media has reached a new point
now with the trumped arrangement
syndrome and their coverage of the
corona virus do you I understand their
reasonable conversations to have by the
way on doing it should we have acted
sooner right how much of a reaction is
an overreaction do we need to take into
account the economy or just take into
account people's health and safety these
are conversations that are being had and
I think should be had and of course I
think we should err on the side of
caution but as it relates to chloroquine
this is something to me if chloroquine
turns out to be beneficial at all in
fighting coronavirus it will hand Ahnold
trump the election so let me before we
get into this whole thing let me give
you some bullet points here the left is
trying to say that Donald Trump told
people to take it at home without the
care of a doctor he did not they're
trying to say that there's very little
science behind this that's not true that
there are no human studies that's not
true that there are no in vitro studies
that's not true that it has no promise
that's not true as a matter of fact
Democrat governors are using it's been
used across the country for a very long
time and across the globe looking it
doesn't mean it's a cure just like don't
say it's a cure but the idea that people
are trying to blame Donald Trump with
this for stupid actions and we'll get to
this very stupid actions - extra extra
spot on behalf of a select few I think
we have no really hear this you'll see
this from all these news headlines are
trying to portray Donald Trump as
against science and this is the point
where the media the hysteria now is not
only about scoring political points but
even though it's not as deadly a virus
as many have touted it to be digitally
virus it can certainly have deadly
consequences - misreport as they are
doing right now on the science the
advancements that are being made with
potential treatments for corona virus in
order to score political points on Trump
in case you think I'm making this up
roll tape
an Arizona couple unfortunately made the
mistake of less production more Rob
as chloroquine because they were Donald
Trump talking about how it's a possible
treatment for coronavirus now tragically
this couple living in Arizona really did
suffer the video sequences of listening
to someone who has no medical expertise
the men unfortunately died soon after
taking the drug and his wife was in
critical condition okay
first let him take the drug which is why
I'm not entirely sure that it's that
unfortunate hold your thoughts here all
the information it's not just the Young
Turks I want to be really clear cuz I'm
no tax no not just those tax the entire
media they jumped on this smear campaign
here you go Global News NPR Guardian New
York Daily News
just listen right now to NBC News as
they try to get the woman in question
whose husband died to place talk about
leading questions here you go
did you see the president's press
conference where did you hear about and
then what and then what did you did you
seek out clean I know some of you are
confused I didn't set up context here on
purpose cleric chloroquine fish tank WA
yeah outlets have been running a stock
image of what looks like a doctor
holding pills but what the couple
actually drank that lady included was
fish tank cleaner so what the headlines
look like is this but what they should
really look like is this just to be
clear that is what actually happened
fish tank cleaner because it had a
similar sounding name and that's
president Trump's fault listen we talked
about coming together unity in this
country we are all one fighting an
invisible foe with the virus and you
want to blame the President of the
United States and really indict this
entire administration by default because
some
drank fish tank cleaner yeah because it
happened to have a name that looked
similar it's not even it's like
chloroquine phosphorus in this product
but by the way here's the thing a lot of
other stuff was in the product it's not
just that in fish tank cleaner so why
would you say oh well good I don't have
Cove at 19 right now right I don't know
coronavirus but I'm gonna take this
anyway because it kills coronavirus that
I don't have and it has other stuff but
I'm okay with that another outlet okay
boom burg they ran an article warning
people that the drug could kill
chloroquine with just 2 grams a lot of
medications can kill with massive
overdoses by the way 2 grams just sounds
like so little so they've been making
all these claims about chloroquine and
here's the thing chloroquine could be a
game-changer this is important for
people who need it you can we can find
all kinds of anecdotal reports from
celebrities to people who've used it but
that's not what we're going to use we
want to get into the actual
peer-reviewed studies and data that we
have despite the fact that people like
The Young Turks and these other
publications are claiming that the drug
has not been approved that no efficacy
has been proven and that it's only
supported but just let them say it so
that we can proof it's just it's problem
is Clark win worked based on some
anecdotal evidence there's studies done
they were limited in scope it's very
wrong listen to one part she said in
there where she said he said it was
already approved and he did he talked
about oh the FDA sped this up normally
they take a long time terrible ones yeah
you know already in great shape no it
makes it sound like it was already
approved when it has not been approved
it makes a sound why it isn't approved
right it is absolutely no there is no he
didn't say that it was accurate
absolutely proved right by the FDA to be
clear chloroquine has been widely used
throughout the entire world approved the
United States since it was in 1947 1949
well there you go you have an overlay
thank God we people were on the ball I
was off by perhaps two years people been
taking it for 70 years now let's be
clear
it hasn't been specifically labeled as a
treatment for coronavirus because some
would argue
depending on where they believe Chinese
propaganda or not whether it
from Wuhan or it came from the United
States troops in somewhere in
november/december okay depending on
which publication you read that could be
Beijing jaylee or New York Times but I
repeat myself by the way hit the
notification bell we are going to have
all the updates tomorrow free mug Club
months the entire month we're going to
do everything in front of the paywall
while you're quarantined along with
thrice a week morning show because we
want to get back we know that a lot of
you are going to get a little stir-crazy
especially if they'll watch more of
these clips here's the crazy thing to me
it really bothers me with with
chloroquine because I'm yeah people
often get mad when you talk about
climate change' you're not a scientist
you're not a doctor right there they
just a Donald Trump who has no medical
expertise sounds to me like you were
voicing an opinion on a medical issue
you don't have medical expertise doesn't
matter you can have an opinion I've had
doctors give me the wrong prescription
before I had doctors give me a treatment
it didn't work as a doc this doesn't
work well thanks for catching that I'm
not it doesn't mean I'm a doctor
supposed to shut up and take it so you
can look at the data that's available
when we talk they say chloroquine is not
a proof it is approved okay it has been
approved by the FDA and it's used
off-label people have been really just
trying to to muddy the waters here there
have been many studies by the way
including peer-reviewed which is shown
chloroquine to be an effective treatment
right a lot of promise and potentially a
prophylactic one of these studies had a
100% efficacy rate in France okay
absolutely if only Donald Trump had said
something like that that would have
clarified the situation that he wasn't
actually prescribing people to go out
and take it but he said if it works
great if it doesn't work I don't know I
think it might work I think that's
exactly what he said when he said if he
wasn't referring to koi pond cleaner no
sponsorship it's big koi that's always
big koi some people like the obviously
The Young Turks the New York Times
they've been saying something else even
saying that really bothers me that
wasn't that specific clip where they say
it's actually it hasn't been proven it's
only been proven like in a in a petri
dish no no I think the word that you
were looking for was in vitro okay
that's also not true we need to be
really clear here there have been
multiple studies peer-reviewed studies
in humans you have one in France it's
been used of course obviously in South
Korea I believe China Belgium other
places across the world and then
after that keep in mind they said this
is working with people it's undeniable
that something is working and so they
did try to study it at a molecular level
in vitro meaning in a petri dish to find
out the mechanism of action and here's
the interesting thing they said hey this
seems to be working too to varying
degrees in human beings why does it work
let's examine it and they found a
plausible mechanism of action I can't
explain it because again I'm not a
medical expert something to do with cell
protection and death but don't take my
word for it and certainly don't take
their word for it the treatment has been
used where's it means I'm trying to
think that a China Canada Belgium South
Korea yeah as a matter of fact result of
been so promising the World Health
Authority they just announced a global
mega trial of the most promising
therapies for corona virus one of them
is chloroquine while we're talking about
Donald Trump and how terrible he is New
York they've received 750,000 doses of
chloroquine 70,000 doses of
hydroxychloroquine and Governor Cuomo
announced that they're going to be
running the trial immediately on the
drug therapy Tuesday we're going to
start the hydroxychloroquine with the
zithromax that's the drug combination
that the president has been talking
about the FDA approved New York State
Department of Health what did you say to
proceed with no matters yeah almost like
context matters this is what's so crazy
we do have to get going so did you have
something that you want yeah yeah I
wanted to say this so what Trump was
trying to say here the entire
conversation was that as a president
Trump sorry what president sure was
trying to say is that we have a
medication that has existed in the world
maybe it's been used for something else
yeah we don't have to come up with a new
drug that we have no idea how the side
effects are going to affect people right
we know all of those things all we have
to do is dial in the treatment and see
if it works that was his whole point and
then he gets lambasted and raked over
the coals for saying you're giving
people fault no I'm not giving people
false hope I'm saying there's something
out there that might work and we're
working on I think what is a president
not Capote this isn't false hope it's
hope we do have a friend why now doesn't
get any hope just going out like Kermit
yeah he shouldn't say hey there's a lot
of promise by the way and if not three
four five studies I mean in vitro study
that shows a reasonable mechanism of
action if you can't sound the alarm the
positive alarm in this case let's recall
a guy at the top of the mountain to tell
people that hey there is some hope out
there for something that would work when
can you ever say it all the clinical
trials which by the way these people
tend to hate because they prefer
alternative medicine something that I
love now - right now we're waiting for
the privatized sector to come up with
more mass to come up with more
respirators to come up with hopefully
better treatments no one's chewing on
cashton guru right no one's going to see
their herbalist and this is so funny to
me where they tried to say oh well honey
this isn't approved but what do you mean
on a second it has been improved in the
United States and it can be prescribed
off-label let's be clear this is why
off-label prescribing is allowed it's
for extreme scenarios like this now it's
been abused where doctors off-label
prescribe things that they shouldn't be
sometimes people views it because they
want to get high that does happen but
clearly not the claim that the case with
chloroquine no one gets a chloroquine
buzz so it has been approved it's gone
through the trout this is what I've been
reading what the Cibola usually it has
to go through phase 1 2 & 3 clinical
trials and it's a really really small
percentage of something that goes
through those different phases of
Charles that's absolutely true why one
of the biggest reasons is not even
whether they work or not but what kind
of side effects they have chloroquine
has already been approved because it has
been proven to be within a reap within a
reasonable bounds readable a safe drug
that people can use it has been
prescribed off-label for a very long
time again because it seems it's for
arthritis for HIV and in this case this
is something that's funny to me the
people who tend to prefer alternative
medicine now all of a sudden we're
talking about the stringent standard of
clinical trials we need a double
double-blind placebo-controlled clinical
trial do you have any idea how hard that
is to do this is the same reason that
bothering people Doyle a big pharma
industry they even come up with a cure
for cancer only treatments do you know
why because when someone is dying of
cancer it's really hard to say hey
there's this new experimental treatment
are you willing to enter into a blind
trial what does that mean means you're
50/50 shot you get a sugar pill no
because I'm bald
I look like Charlie Brown with the
progeria special do you understand this
don't want to go into some blind control
trial where a doctor doesn't even know
especially in this scenario who is going
to put forward the money and who is
going to want to participate in a blind
double-blind placebo-controlled clinical
trial if they have coronavirus there one
of the cases where they could be at risk
of death and they don't need to go
through a trial because their doctor can
prescribe it to them immediately
off-label and if someone's alternative
is potentially dying tomorrow or not
making it through the night because
they're 85 years old with pneumonia and
living on a respirator dear god it's
borderline medical malpractice if a
doctor's gonna try everything in his
power regardless of what the ask for the
New York Times say so when we talk about
unity this is something really bothers
let's find some common ground really
common ground you are willing right now
you're saying that Donald Trump is going
to let people die by allowing people to
go pick up a beer to store some time
before Easter that if we stop this
quarantine we're young healthy people
can go out and contribute to the economy
so they have jobs to come back to that
he doesn't care about human life when
you were deliberately misleading people
and trying to kill trying to kill hope
for a treatment that in this scenario
for a drug that has been approved for
over half a century and there's no
financial incentive or very little
financial incentive to conduct clinical
trials we have the best possible case
scenario that we could have at this
point a few large sample studies and an
in vitro study that shows a reasonable
mechanism of action but instead you in
order to score political points are
willing to let people die because you
hate Donald Trump Bravo come together
right now over the New York Times go
screw yourself
I forgot to breathe there for a second
and now I'm sounding like the teenager
from The Simpsons if you liked this
video subscribe hit the notification
bell one of these videos is playing in a
box and come back to the live stream
Thursday at its 8 p.m. right 8 p.m.
Eastern because we'll be talking about
the free mug club month where we'll be
doing the entire show not just for mug
club members but all of you who are
getting cabin fever amid to quarantine
and hey don't forget eat your vegetables
drink your milk take your clerk way